bonjour jean louis bourlanges bonjour
l'ukraine a obtenu hier officiellement
l'accord des 27 pour devenir un pays
candidat à l'adhésion à l'union
européenne à court terme est ce que cela
va changer de quoi que ce soit pour le
pays donc je crois que c'est ainsi une
politique très fort c'était ainsi une
politique qui était demandé par les
ukrainiens et je pense que c'était
quelque chose que l'on pouvait leur
accorder d'autant que fait il fallait
montrer que l'avenir de l'ukraine est à
l'ouest que l'avenir de l'ukraine et en
solidarité en union profonde avec
l'union européenne
cela dit c'est une affaire qui va se
développer très progressivement très
lentement je crois qu'il ne faut pas du
tout sous-estimé la complexité d'un
phénomène d'adhésion au clean pas
spécifiquement celui l'ukraine mais
l'union européenne c'est une mécanique
de précision on ne peut pas faire
n'importe quoi si on veut que ça ne se
dérègle pas vladimir poutine a dit il ya
quelques jours que l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne ne lui
posait aucun problème est ce qu'il faut
le croire quand il dit ça écoutez moi je
crois que me l'a dit meilleures poutines
vit dans un monde un peu parallèle est
il des déclarations qui sont parallèles
au monde dans lequel il vit ça fait 3
par elle donc là moi je
il insiste sur l'idée que ça la grande
menace à laquelle il est supposé faire
face c'est celle de l'otan ce qui est
absurde le temps n'a jamais été une
alliance offensive mais il n'a pas pu en
effet se sentir sous la pression
grandissante de la fin de mon côté je ne
vois pas pourquoi il se serait senti
sous la pression grandissante de le
temps pendant toute la guerre froide eu
le temps ça une politique d'une extrême
retenue sur la hongrie sur la
tchécoslovaquie après nous avons
considéré que l'ukraine ne devait pas
rentrer dans le temps tant qu'elle ne
demandait pas réellement parce que
c'était un pays qui était sorti brement
de l'union soviétique avec l'accord des
autres états russes on avait des
garanties qui ont été apportées dans le
cadre de la convention de budapest à la
la souveraineté de l'ukraine ces
garanties ont été
brutalement et unilatéralement
méprisés par les russes et nous ne
sommes pas vraiment intervenus donc
véritablement et pendant toutes les
discussions notamment celle qu'a menées
le président macron avec le président
poutine il a été mis sur la table toutes
les formes possibles
d'organisation de la sécurité de
l'europe
de l'europe orientale et centrale et
c'est manifestement poutine n'en voulait
pas son projet très clairement établie
il veut rétablir l'ancienne puissance de
la russie où l'union soviétique on ne
peut discuter des le terme il estime que
tous ses combats pourraient revenir
effacer les traces du règles de la fin
de la guerre froide sont légitimes c'est
là tout alors si on se projette dans
quinze ou vingt ans au moment où
l'ukraine seraient en situation d'entrée
dans l'union européenne et qu'à ce
moment là une partie du territoire
ukrainien était toujours occupée ou
annexés par là aussi que se passerait-il
je crois que c'est impossible de
répondre à votre question parce que ce
qui est clair et on l'a bien vu après
l'adhésion de chypre qui était un peu
téméraire de ce point de vue là quelle
que soit la qualité des chypriotes et là
le plaisir qu'on a de les avoir parmi
nous il faut que la paix soit rétablie
le le promu la première condition pour
que ces négociations se développe mais
c'est la même chose pour les rapports
avec le temps il faut qu'on ait un
statut l'ukraine qui soit solidement
établie et alors cette guerre va durer
je ne sais combien de temps mais il faut
que ce qu'on ne peut pas admettre un
pays en guerre ce qui veut dire que
l'union européenne entière serait le
temps guerre
on ne peut pas l'admettre comme ça il
faut donc pour que cette cette
candidature se concrétise il faut qu'on
aboutisse à un règlement pacifique avec
la russie et ça moi je crois que ce
règlement est très nécessaire il faut
aller le plus vite possible mais ce plus
vite possible n'en sera pas moins
extrêmement lent parce que les russes
n'ont pas du tout l'intention de
négocier tant qu'ils n'ont pas gagné et
ne sont pas en mesure de gagner
décisivement fort heureusement est ce
que la rapidité exceptionnelle avec
laquelle l'ukraine ont obtenu le statut
de candidat ne va pas faire des jaloux
parmi les pays qui frappent aussi à la
porte de l'union si c'est même le cas
ils ont protesté les uns et les autres
tout ça me paraît très très excessif et
ma part est reflété une certaine
méconnaissance de ce qu'est l'union
européenne serre c'est pas un concours
de vitesse c'est pas un concours moi
d'abord toit après c'est un ensemble de
disciplines
ça n'a rien à voir avec la richesse
d'ailleurs du pays mais de discipline
démocratique et juridique librement
consenti vérifier parce que quand vous
rentrez dans l'union européenne
vous participez à un système politique
extrêmement sophistiquée avec un
parlement commission un conseil des
ministres et si dans la majorité
qualifiée une banque centrale à terme si
vous entrez dans une cour de justice
donc vous êtes ce sont des gens qui
interviendront dans nos décisions comme
nous interviendrons dans les leurs donc
tout ça c'est de la mécanique de
précision et sauf qu'on l'oublié un peu
trop moi je connais bien il vient faire
européenne et je crois que ça n'est pas
ce n'est pas facile pour l'instant si ça
n'avance pas dans les balkans c'est pas
de notre faute si les bulgares bloque la
macédoine et certains réformes sont
assez lentes à ceux à se mettre en place
mais il n'y a pas de notre part de sac
politique
j'aimerais lui en vue pour l'enjeu qu'on
évoque un peu la situation politique
vous avez été réélu dimanche dernier
député des hauts-de-seine est ce que
vous avez bien compris ce qu emmanuel
macron a proposé mercredi soir ses
adversaires politiques pour répondre à
l'absence de majorité absolue à
l'assemblée nationale oui je crois que
c'est cette
île à il a estimé qu'il était il a dit
qu'il était disposé à
considérer ce qui est toutes les
demandes qui viendrait des partis
d'opposition et qui sont le multi donc
l'appoint est nécessaire pour avoir une
majorité absolue
à l'assemblée maintenant il faut que
chacun sache ce qu'ils veulent a dit
j'aimerais savoir jusqu'où vous êtes
prêts à aller mais jusqu'où vous aimerez
aller dans quelle matière
maintenant tout moi je crois que le
problème est et doit être posée fait il
ya deux façons d'aborder les choses soit
on fait du cas par cas à vrai dire ce
que la ville le gouvernement à gitex
partex il n'y a pas d'accord global
c'est ce que nous ferons avec un risque
assez grand
d'immobilisme paralysie est ce qu est ce
que la france peut s'accommoder d'un
mouvement législatif beaucoup plus
laborieux et donc d'un nombre de lois a
fait c'est possible c'est possible que
avec moins de loiron on soit obligé de
s'intéresser à des changements qui se
ferait par d'autres biais par le biais
d' ministre hâtif réglementaire c'est
possible qu'on puisse travailler comme
ça l'autre idée c'est de dire non mais
écoutez il ya de grandes différences
entre entre les parties a manifestement
ce que j'appelle un front populiste un
bloc populis qu'étant en désaccord très
fondamentale avec les autres partis sur
sur le rapport à la russie sur le
rapport à l'europe sur le rapport aux
états unis sur l'économie de marché sur
le mot
lolo le oui le système le système social
bon si ce désaccord est elle il faut on
n'arrivera pas à trouver une entente
mais en revanche si si par exemple les
gens de l air s'ils réfléchissent bien
est-ce qu'ils sont plus proches de nous
que du front que du rassemblement
national faut qu'il le dise pas qu'il le
sache or pour l'instant ce qui est
frappant c'est qu'à l'air a énormément
de mal à choisir pour une raison simple
c'est qu'ils sont eux mêmes divisés donc
ce que le président la république dise
et faites votre choix et je suis prêt à
en discuter merci jean le bourlanges
même journée